Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Sam from New York City. Sam,
welcome to the program. What's going on?
Speaker 2: Thanks so much. I sort of had a
question about, you know, I need to cover some of
the Trump rallies in your time or unfortunately,
very young kids, you know, three or four or five
that are there. I tend to skip over that part. I
agree with that because I really do see them
as victims of a very narrow media space where
they've just been fed propaganda. Yeah. So what
I wonder sort of theoretically is at what point,
at what age in their development, we then sort of
turn and start pulling them responsible because I
really struggle with that era. You have a
three year old I'm not going to blame the
three year old for having Trump views the big
four square like a Trump. But the three year
old's going to grow up doing just the same media
diet. Yeah. So is there a point where then we
can start holding that former three year old?
Speaker 1: Here's why this is really tough.
If we had a system of education in the United
States where we knew with confidence, Sam,
that starting in fifth grade and then definitely
by seventh and eighth grade and 100% in high
school, we were really teaching kids. Here's
how you think for yourself. Here's how you
think critically. Here's how you evaluate claims.
Here is how you do research, etc.. If we did that,
I would be very comfortable saying to you, Listen,
by the time kids are 15, we can start to say.
You were responsible for the things you now
believe that would be. That's a hypothetical.
But the truth is, many schools don't teach this
stuff. I visited rural, conservative parts of
the country where people's entire kind of socio
cultural lives were revolve around their churches
and the local shooting range, if that's what
they're exposed to until they're 18 or whatever.
And I don't know what the answer is because
they sort of are in a bubble they were born
into indefinitely. So that, you know, blame
I don't know about. I don't know about the
word blame necessarily. But I think as
people get closer and closer to age 18,
I think they are more and more independent
in all ways. And that would be both legally,
but also in terms of the things they believe.
I mean, listen, if you look at kids at 14,
they are still very likely to hold the same
political views as their parents. Even at 18,
that's still the case because in general, people
continue to hold the political views that you're
more likely to hold the political views of the
family you were brought up in that we know that
that that persists. So I don't know when there's a
clean break and we say I mean, listen, a four year
old is a four year old. They're not thinking for
themselves about politics. A 12 year old might be,
depending on how they were brought up. A 15 year
old should be, but we can't really be sure. I
don't know the answer. It's it's a very gray area.
Speaker 2: Yeah. No, that's actually how I feel.
I appreciate your nuanced vibe on it, but I
also disclosed that with breast cancer causing
some controversy, my own belief and where you
get the best bagel in New York City, please.
All right. Absolute bagel, 107th and
Broadway. I don't know if you're familiar.
Speaker 1: I never get
there. I never get up there.
Speaker 2: All right. Well, if you ever are. I'm
telling you, it's so. Darn good bagel. I'm telling
you, I believe strongly that I would be prepared.
Speaker 1: Listen, here's the thing.
There's hundreds of places with great bagels in
New York City. You know, that's just the reality.
Speaker 2: And now know I'm.
Speaker 1: There and there's dozens
of places with a great brisket. And, you know,
so it's almost like a little bit of a joke. But
where are you on places like, for example, Russ
and Daughters where like they're they've become
so known and touristy that it's like, yes,
it's good, but like, is it as good as people
make it out to be? I don't know. I don't.
Speaker 2: Know. You will never catch me
waiting in that, like, two hour line. And Russ and
Daughters, maybe it's marginally better if someone
else wants to wait for me and let me play a bite
of that pastrami sandwich. I'm all for it. But no,
I avoid all those places, just like I avoid,
you know, Times Square, you know? Exactly.
Speaker 1: Times Square is just the best.
Yep. I'm with you. All right, my friend.
Speaker 2: You know, go in there.
Okay. Sorry. Yeah. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Okay. Sam, taking Sam shot out of
a cannon on the bagel topic. And I understand
it. I mean, it is one of the foremost issues
that that humanity is contending with right now